no what we are the sum our minds our
egos our preferences are the sum of our
learned experiences okay and every
single person has had different
experiences yes one of the things I try
to teach people is okay at a given
moment you're having an experience right
okay we're having experience okay and
before you had an experience so there's
that experience of that moment how many
experiences are you missing
so many uh 700 billion zillion quillion
every single moment yes right somebody
else is being programmed with those
experiences you're being programmed with
this experience then the next moment is
another experience another no one has
ever had the same experience as you not
meet think about that no one has ever
had it and no one ever will you're the
most unique thing in the universe and so
is everybody else but since we're the
sum of a learned experiences or at least
our psyche is we're not the
Consciousness is not we are watching the
sum of our learned experiences The
Observer watches right so that's where I
take it take it pick a bone with Skinner
right it's not that man just the similar
experiences man is the Consciousness the
awareness of being but the psyche they
look at which is what he was talking
about is the cellular experiences so
everybody's a summer learned experiences
I never had different experiences so
you're absolutely right how can they be
wrong you think you're right you think
you're right she said don't dare do that
I can't believe you did that that was so
wrong right because based on your
experiences that's out of the question
on somebody else's experience they don't
know what you're talking about that's
why this whole politics stuff is so
stupid right it's it's like there I they
don't understand they're just expressing
the summon learned experiences and if
you had a different experience one
different experience you would have a
different opinion right
or wrong right I tell I tell a story and
pull it around a time it's a very
powerful story I tell a story that
there's two kids seven to eight years
old in the back of the station wagon and
the parents are driving to go on a
vacation and they're playing you know I
spy that kind of a game back there
playing around and so the sister who's a
year older says I spy and oh treated the
right and the little boy turns around
and at that exact moment there was a
terrible accident with body parts and
blood and he's traumatized for life okay
they can't even bring them back and
never get into a car he can't do
anything could that happen right what if
she had said oh look over here
his whole life's changed I don't accept
that
that's that's ridiculous that's not fair
that's out of the question you
understand that as your entire life was
based on one random moment yeah they
look somewheres or some okay and so you
but that is how it is we're programmed
with itself and so anyone that has gone
through the their lifetime experiences
they think they're right they think this
is how can they think otherwise
you're saying that they're programming
with that yeah okay so or I don't know
any sensitive political object subjects
but any subject you take where there's
two sides is because somebody had enough
experiences on this side so they say I
know what I'm talking about I had a
sister who went through that right this
person well I had a sister and she okay
and if you had different experiences it
takes real humility to admit that if you
had different experiences you would see
it differently yeah so yes you're right
that from a personal point of view
everybody thinks they're right and
nobody's right right because they just
have these I I call those experiences
statistically insignificant
all right and it was the fact that you
picked up one point out of the billions
that existed at that moment and that's
all you're ever getting that as we call
statistically insignificant data
a wise person laosue he said or wise
being he said A wise man never argues
for what purpose
it's not that they don't try to raise
the world but you're not fighting with
it because you understand with
compassion I understand how you see it
that way I don't see it that way but I
understand how you see it that way
because you had different experiences
now how can we get along
if everyone was that humble and everyone
was that open and they respected that's
called respect right and we we could
find a way to do much better than we're
doing a good way
um
for sure
why is it so hard to see ourselves
because in those in that example of some
somebody doing something and them being
wrong
it's hard to see that we've been
programmed a certain way
why is there this sort of
conundrum where or this challenge of
being a human where we really can't see
ourselves the saying you know we don't
see things as they are we see things as
we are but yet we can't see ourselves we
don't understand in that interaction
when somebody does something like they
drive slow on the road it's because I am
crazy and neurotic about driving fast
like why can't I see that instead why do
I see them as the problem this to me is
like one of the sort of big challenges
and Mysteries of being a human is this
inability to really have that
self-reflection you you are distracted
by that which is the loudest whatever it
is if there's a big noise outside and
we're having a conversation you're not
paying attention to me anymore you're
paying attention to the noise if you
drop a hammer on your toe right you're
not paying attention to the rest of your
body silly I don't know why it puts
attention there it's important rehearse
the most but that's true okay you have
thoughts that are more powerful because
they're charged you had experience in
the past you had a divorce 20 years ago
and all of a sudden you hear the
person's name it's not the same person
but you hear the name all of a sudden
you're lost so you get distracted by
that which is most pulling on your
Consciousness into straps your
Consciousness that's your answer and
that's why people can't come back here
right because they get pulled back down
into the heartache into the heart love
the same right I'm madly in love with
somebody I can't stand them oh in other
words your heart has changed and you got
sucked into it
so is you said the charge and I want to
talk about energy chakras because you
say you come back down or you need to go
up to transcend Beyond something that an
event happens and they get stored that's
right lower so essentially you come out
of your higher chakras and you come down
into this primitive lower chakras in the
first second third and that's where you
get stuck and so it's stuck energy am I
am I gathering information right you
will love my new book this is this is
exactly what a new book talks about why
do you think I love this book okay so so
basically
the the new book literally says what is
mine and how did it get the way it is
all right and it starts with the Zen
concept of empty mind there's nothing in
there it's like a computer that's so
powerful but there's no software it
doesn't mean it's stupid right it's just
not right now doing anything it's not
creating thoughts all right then what
happens the world comes in through your
senses because that's what it does right
and it builds patterns in your mind yeah
right that's what's happening you're
seeing it inside all right well if those
patterns are normal a tree a car or this
or that they just go right through yeah
I always tell my people you're already
99 and like 99 of every single thing
that comes into your senses makes it
right through
yeah I mean sure I mean I love the
analogy in the book that you use about
the I think it's maybe a blue car I
think it's a blue car and if you see a
blue car go down the road it means
nothing to someone but if your
ex-boyfriend had a blue car if you see
the blue car all of a sudden bam that
blue car means something that's right
how many cars do you see go by that mean
nothing that's right that's right 99
these leaves grass everything makes it
through then they don't experience it
you just experience it read it out right
yeah it comes in which is a group which
is good news but then what happens is
something comes in like a rattlesnake
and it's scary yeah it is naturally
scary I've seen coiled rattlesnakes I
live in the woods around the country all
right and they are scary all right and
you're going to get this this vibration
like that it's not comfortable okay fine
but then it crawled away does that
discomfort crawl away no because you
won't let it pass through you use those
hands and they're saying no I don't want
to have this experience I don't like
that I had the experience probably you
did have this yeah
programming has told you rattlesnakes
are dangerous I can even even if I
didn't ever have that programming it
sends off Vibes that are meant to scare
you oh the nature of a rattlesnake is
get away from me okay it comes in but
when it crawls away it could pass
through doesn't mean you didn't learn
but it passed through but no I was so
uncomfortable that I don't want to have
had the experience pay attention to that
right I literally don't want to have had
it so it happened outside but I don't
have to let it pass all the way inside I
can suppress it there's Freud I can push
away the event inside and it goes down
your subconscious and then bees the way
you talked earlier that we have all this
stuff stored in there have we not made a
collection of every bad experience we
ever had yeah for sure we have if you
make a collection of everything that
ever disturbs you you're going to be
disturbed
they were so silly we're supposed to be
simple and yet so hard uh it's so
ridiculous all right so we do that and
we it's almost instinctual like if I
throw a ball at you you throw your hands
up that's what we do inside we use those
inner hands no no I don't have this and
we push it away and only because you're
being so high I'll give you the other
side you meet somebody and they're
beautiful you see a butterfly comes and
lands on your arm as I use in the book
that's a nice experience let's push that
one away I can't wait for that day I
dream about that when I'm hiking I'm
like just land on it when the butterfly
flies away we don't like that we want it
to stay there so we can't cling to the
butterfly because it flew away but we
can cling to the experience
we can keep the experience inside so
that we miss every other experience
because the busy thinking about the
butterfly and busy wanting the butterfly
to happen
you understand that these are both
positive and negative subscribers so you
push away the negative ones you cling to
the positive one and you now that's
where your personality came from you
scored this these events but not all
events you only store the powerful ones
you understand that that's what he said
the powerful weather they're good or bad
that's exactly right they just reach a
threshold and they are now programmed
and you store them and now your entire
personality is built around that you sit
there and say where do I want to live
where there's no rattlesnakes where
where how can I see the butterfly again
those are your likes and dislikes and
you're like people I you meet a person
that you love them to Pieces until you
find any cholesterol snakes
yeah right so is it equally dangerous to
Value both of them and store both of
them I I I don't people aren't ready to
talk at this absolute level of TR of
non-duality and Transcendence so I only
threw that in because you've been asked
those High questions right because it
does mess you up okay if you go into a
restaurant have a beautiful experience
the music is perfect the menu is perfect
the people they are sitting the distance
away is just right the right number of
people in there right and say I want to
go back I want to go back to laws where
the restaurant was right you are going
to be disappointed that's exactly right
that's what I was thinking of I was
thinking about having an experience that
you loved going on a trip that you love
and then I've done this before where you
try and recreate it because you're like
this was amazing and and exactly what
you said happens you're I would say
always disappointed you will always be
and if you bring friends with you wait
till you see this right then you're
embarrassed
it became a bad experience became a
negative experience right so the answer
the answer is people always ask me do
can I really not enjoy positive
experiences I said you've got so many
negative ones just work on that don't
worry about the rest we'll go that
that's graduate school
the positives are nothing at this point
in time I wish that was your problem
okay there's too many positive thoughts
in there but why do you have all these
Nate whites why naturally people say to
me I practice positive thinking I'm
terrible you know I always say to that
person why
and that is positive thinking but why do
why do you practice the problem with
thinking well because I don't what
happens if you don't it's negative yeah
why why is it that way this book gets
into that the whole Foundation of what
you built in there is trying to release
all the time just like it comes up in
your dreams it comes up all day and you
and all you remember all this stuff that
bothers you and everything stimulates
your stuff yeah okay and that's why it's
the way it is in there so what's the
answer get that stuff out and you said
that earlier I was very proud of you
right that you got this stuff in there
you store all this stuff in there then
it becomes how do you do that because if
you get that stuff out you're filled
with love all the time
[Music]